now i noticed the gas prices on the way
in today did you know you're yeah you're
too high
coming in real high
well now that now they've turned me down
yeah
yeah yeah i just came in hot yep i came
in hot because i wanted to start the uh
start the show gas prices are high
everything prices are high cause them
oil men have been wrestling them prices
up you know
hustling and harassing i like when we
find episodes it seems like every
episode uh still is just as applicable
today as it was in 2008. well
[ __ ] don't change as they say you know
because uh we won't change human beings
will refuse to change and learn it's so
fascinating last night just to watch the
news and maybe it's just because i'm an
old man now but i see i see the same
stories that were told in 2008 people
talking about a recession and they can't
and it's just the same thing it's just
the same thing that's happening
a bubble was blown and a bubble has
burst and people can't believe it they
just can't believe it's never going to
go back it's never going to go back it
can't this one's different explain to me
why the prices of gas have to go up i
understand the shortage issues i
understand the war i understand the the
pipeline access issues but why do the
prices actually have to go up give me
money
it's right it's simply that right isn't
it that's good
that leads into our next guest paul
krugman is going to be coming on and
talk about macro economics
hey rob why don't you back off that mic
off that mic
it's gotta just be greed right it's like
man we're gonna take a big financial hit
here if we keep selling gas at the same
price so what we'll do is we won't take
that hit we'll raise the price
we'll lay off a butt greed
i'm thinking great in the oil business
i'm thinking a touch of grief wait a
second humans human beings
now here's the thing though uh you guys
have you guys have seen the documentary
the the corporation correct
i have not no the corporation it was a
documentary back in 2003 rob i think you
and i watched it together yes i remember
[ __ ] from 2003
well this this uh this this documentary
did a really good job of kind of
explaining um you know the the sort of
inherent problem with the corporation in
general is that it's got to continue to
the profits have to grow it's a living
it has to feed it must grow grow yeah oh
by law it has to grow so no matter what
the uh
you know prices are or how horrible it
is for the consumers what they do it
whatever they have to do to
um you know keep making incrementally
higher profits every year that's their
that's literally its purpose as a
corporation it's a monster that um we've
created that uh
needs to be slain
a what
why hey wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait back off your socialist agenda here
you lived left
leftist thug corporations are gods
we gotta tear it down
if we tear it down we don't have a
television show but guys we have it
under control we have we we're like i
don't wanna have a television show
[Music]
glenn um you're looking great today i
have to say yeah why the sunnies why the
duster
i'm just you know in one of those moods
where you just want to wrap yourself in
a warm duster and uh and throw on some
sunglasses because you're just not fully
awake and you just gotta
you know hide from the world a little
bit but while also looking awesome yeah
oh yeah i want to say point out to fans
uh that this is the actual duster that
was actually on the show i got it from
sabrina rosen who's our uh head of
costumes had a wardrobe
and uh she she pulled it out of storage
for us so that's the one
charlie i did also ask if we could get
your oil man costume from this episode
but they couldn't pull it in time for me
but oh my god
there are so many memes from this
episode
both outside in
in the world in the comedy community and
just the general public and also within
us and our little
inside joke uh meme system that we have
did you notice a few of those glenn
charlie no
no what are you talking about what's the
inside joke mean what is uh but things
we say amongst ourselves like in the
office or whatever yeah so like what was
one of them one of them would be uh uh
that is what happened that is that is
what happened no charlie says yes you
guys are saying something about how my
boss
was confused for uh braininess that is
what happened that
we've said that amongst each other as an
inside joke for
20 years there's a lot of good things
about this episode i mean actual car
crashes yeah uh
zach knight
exactly explosions yep the slow and
eventual total and complete destruction
of his uh you know honda accord or
whatever the whole car that was is so
funny
the guy that plays random guy is one of
our closest friends zach knighton
who is currently on magnum pi and moves
to hawaii oh and we never see him we'll
never see him again because i don't know
that he's ever coming back
um
he's so he's such a hawaii guy i mean
what could there have been a better gig
for zach knighton
than a gig that takes place in hawaii i
don't think so yeah so right so the
random guy have you know did you notice
how how poor the visual effects were in
this episode
no oh
they're terrible
you mean the fireballs the fireballs i
thought those are fireballs the
fireballs are fantastic fireballs the
fireballs are fantastic the greens we're
talking about the green screen oh some
of the kians in the van you mean like
jumping me jumping out of the back of
the van oh just off the street just
and nobody's looking at the background
when that happens everyone's just
staring here facing
wild card pitches yeah but then you jump
out
your eyes my eyes drawn to it and then i
don't know what you thought i jumped out
of a moving van man i don't know i know
i thought you're spoiling this for me
now i really thought you guys did that's
fair maybe my memory is yeah my number's
just yeah no he jumped out of a moving
van he went full tom cruise yeah broke
his ankle and kept going have any of you
ever jumped out of a moving car no no um
no i mean you know uh i i've jumped out
of the car as it's coming to a stop
but that's not what you're asking i
jumped off of a moving train but it was
moving so slowly oh really yes like i
don't even know that i rolled i think we
just hopped just
i've jumped out of a cab and booked it
before yeah yeah like uh
oh sort of like a like a dash situation
yeah oh yeah so as to not pay for
something yes
yes
i can tell you the time it happened it
wasn't a common practice but uh
i was at a notable composer cormic
bluestone's apartment in new york and
i'd taken the subway back to mine it was
about 4 00 a.m you know and uh i got to
my apartment and realized i left my keys
at cormix and you know the trains run so
slow at that time
and i i probably was inebriated uh i
said all right i'm going to hop a cab
back but i knew i didn't have any money
so i hopped the cab back up towards
corman corey's neighborhood just being
like all right when is the moment where
i go firing out of this cab and just
book it and then i waited for like a
one-way road that i knew the cabbie
couldn't go up and then i took off and
the guy didn't even [ __ ]
he didn't even bat an eye where he was
like i [ __ ] knew it probably you know
[Laughter]
this little scumbag but now i don't do
that now i don't have to do that no you
you can afford to pay the cab i could
pay the cash yeah it's good i know but
it's still fun to steal food from the
mouths of uh you know
it is it is you know what i mean that's
coming out of his box
yeah well now i'm an over tipper you
know always making up for that
did you guys notice that the woman who
doesn't say anything um but she's
actually quite funny who you're who you
are playing you were you are as the oil
as the oil man did you recognize that
actor oh she is on a very now i didn't
look this up so i'm just guessing but
let's see if let's see if i'm right um
she's on a very big television show
right now and she's she's great in the
show and she stands out in the show
um
i don't know i didn't notice if i'm
wrong about this we'll cut that cut that
or meg will keep it in
but i i'm almost sure she has a very
specific look
she had a familiar looking face for sure
let's pop it up on the screen for them
why didn't she have any lines was she an
extra did we cut her lines don't know
she may have been background because we
couldn't afford to we were
we were terrible about that back in the
day we were like how we could probably
get away with doing this without um the
actor actually saying words because
the second they say
the second they say one line yeah if you
have to pay them more um way more
significantly more melora hart okay no
and
it looks like she's been in a bunch of
anime
as a voice okay
actress i don't know rob
is she on the show
succession
oh you think that won't no that's not
the same moment even if i'm wrong which
i could absolutely be you are can we do
a side can we do a side by side
i know the woman you're thinking you
know the woman i'm talking about and you
know the woman and the yeah there's a
there's a similarity to their looks they
don't they don't look alike man they
look exactly the same it's the same
person she changed her name they they
don't even look even a little bit to me
i i know
i see what you see rob for sure oh my
god get the [ __ ] out
look at this woman's face
okay now go back to the other one no
this is 10 years ago oh my god
you guys are terrain now similar
okay yeah all right i see i see uh
similar
i see i see the similarity same
not the same same yeah not the same but
i do see some similarity there similar
creeps creeps creeps i'm going to need
well we'll put this side
they look very similar but not
not the same you know like well she
changed her name it is the same person
this is a fun little depression
what are the odds that melora so and so
just disappeared
and then on the scene comes
this woman jeannie berlin
are you confessing to a crime
a shout out to uh sonny lee and pat
walsh who uh are
are credited on on this episode uh
for some writing and uh very very funny
guys yeah definitely if uh an episode
you he that gets memed quite a bit
because there are people who try to do
this all the time in real life yeah
resell gas oh yeah yeah they get busted
reselling the gas i like when there's
just enough logic to the plot you know
where we're like okay it's stupid but i
could see why they're thinking about
doing it that is what the industry does
the industry
the industry
the gasoline industry sure creates the
gasoline has a supply waits for the
demand to go up
and then
adjust the prices accordingly yeah and
then
so it's funny how crazy
how they determine those things you know
so that there's like literally a guy
who's like all right it's gonna be point
three cents uh higher today so you know
and then the guy's gotta get up there
and he's gotta change the sign
you know he's got he's got his little
he's got his ladder and he's like and he
doesn't get you know he's like what is
this
really point three cents you know or
whatever
it's uh it's bizarre rob you worked at a
gas station did you ever have to change
the sign i did no we never did and this
this was a time that there was it was
not digital signs in fact i don't still
even 2023 don't see a lot of 2022 i
don't see a lot of digital signs i think
it's a lot of going out there with a big
stick i never had to do that but i do
remember it never being more than 99
cents
now this was 1994.
but it was never more than 99 cents and
i remember everybody in philadelphia
saying if this thing goes to a dollar
yeah we're [ __ ]
mine was two dollars if it goes past two
dollars by the time i was driving that's
what
could never go past well here we are
it's uh seven dollars a gallon now none
of us would know because
because we're off the grid we're off the
grid we're socially responsible what's
wrong with you creeps still buying gas
a lot of options don't you care about
the environment you don't have to get a
tesla there's a lot of options you know
what i mean
we'll suck off that grid whatever
lots of brands yeah go get yourself some
solar panels and a and a tesla power
wall right above people can afford this
stuff right yeah yeah uh
yeah
why aren't you soldered yet
yeah get solar creeps damn the solar
companies are itching like a hound dog
to give you something
we don't believe in the sun here you
know
we believe in the earth and its elements
i love i love that you do that accent in
the in the in the episode like that is
an accent that i still hear actors do
when they play southern people that it
just does not exist anymore it is not an
accent that is that actually exists in a
real human being no one talks like that
like it's literally people watching
foghorn leg horns
that's how people talk in the sound
no one talks like are you saying that
people don't have accents in the south
or don't have that accent no no i'm
saying they don't sound like that their
accent doesn't sound like that yeah
that's a cartoon game yeah that's that's
a cartoon
well it's not even yeah it's an
exaggeration it's also just it's just
not it's just not an accent that people
have anymore i do think that like you
know it's just kind of like it's kind of
like that thing that kevin spacey was
doing on on a house of car what was the
name of that show house of cards uh
house of cards like that is also an
accent that a lot of actors do they play
that sort of genteel southern gentleman
talks like this and it's like dude there
hasn't been a a a gentleman in the south
who talks like that since the [ __ ]
1920s like
it's just it's not an accent that exists
anymore i mean you're not you you're
you're you're you're you're you're
somebody
yeah
grandfather yeah that kind of effect paw
paw jamie pretty much talked like that
and how old was paw patrol he was he was
old yeah it was just
did in the past possibly speak like that
but then that was spread via cartoon
character
and then from there
um people who did not grow up in the
south uh assumed that that would might
be the accent and then just sort of
propagate your suggestion
that is what i'm suggesting yosemite sam
what a good an authentic accent
but you can say the same thing about
bugs bunny who who was doing groucho
marx and people did speak that like that
at a time but we don't now now you don't
have
actors playing northerners doing a
groucho marx yeah yeah well it's person
by person right i'm sure there's
somebody in texas who talks like this
right but they're probably older and
yeah i don't know like uh
same with the boston accent you hear
people like really lay on the boston
accent thick and most people like have
like a little bit of it and they're
dropping their arms a little bit and
then you run into that one guy where
it's just like
thick as can be but just so just so
we're being clear i'm not even talking
about the extremeness of the accent
there are people in the south that have
very strong strong accents they just
don't sound like that um
you know they just sound different from
that uh but you know it's the kind of
thing that you like you know i grew up
in the south so i i
i maybe have a more of a refined year
for it you know just like you would a
little bit more nuanced to you
you're just going out of your way to say
my bad accent was bad that's what i'm
picking up on like i feel like you're i
feel like you're jumping through hoops
to come down on you to come down on the
accent and like listen no i know it was
a cartoon accent no i know you do i know
i know that's why it's funny that's i
like that you do that and and but that's
why i also you know i threw in the uh i
see that i see your gestures
i mean your sunglasses and your duster
and your judgments on accents
i say i say i
i'm offended
[Music]
how are you guys doing these days
money-wise i'm good are you asking us
for money rob well recently i thought i
don't know how long this bear market is
going to go on for so i should start a
little side hustle to stay afloat and
that s p is hitting you hard huh yeah
yeah yep so i turned to our friends at
shopify and i gotta say i've never known
success like this your wikipedia does
describe you as a businessman in the
opening line so i i thought that you
would know okay well they probably got
wind of my shopify and that's why they
that's why they wrote that in there now
you're doing crazy business on there rob
crazy profit margins what are we talking
about all green candles buddy to the
moon that sounds like true unbridled
success to me you know you have won at
capitalism i log on and i immediately
hear the succession theme song in my
head i can't say it
see shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses so anyone can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed i mean on
and i love that shopify helps me reach
customers across the world and social
media whether on facebook instagram tick
tock pinterest or more go to shopify.com
sunny that's all lowercase
shopify.com sunny for free
day trial and get full access to
shopify's entire suite of features grow
your business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
sunny right now shopify.com
sunny
[Music]
oh my god the bank scene yeah which
which is so clearly
yeah that's like
how many scenes have we shot in cugino's
at that point two three
uh
yeah i think
at least
um
that's one
of the best scenes from top to bottom i
think that's in the show this is a
strange bank this is this is no this is
a stranger your boss is a woman now this
is a strange bag yeah
it's the idea that we went in there
knowing it was going to be a man we knew
that's why
but then okay fine
right it's a new world we're progressive
we get it but your boss we need to talk
to him um yeah i talked to that guy the
one of my favorite things we ever did
was like the three of us sitting across
are four or five of us sitting across
from a desk from someone who is a sane
person who is dealing with basically
insane people and this is a particularly
good version of it yeah and that actor
is so wonderful because whenever we find
when we find that straight person
sometimes they're not funny and she was
really funny so her reactions were great
lots of things came out of this um it's
a little tiny thing but
um i think he'll understand more better
yeah um is that the first time you said
it i think that's
that's so funny he's going to understand
yeah what do you think her intelligence
while speaking about foreign right right
but we got it under control we got it
all under control
well it's just you know our way of
continuing to signal to the audience
that these are not good people there's
not educated people
um you know and yet they act superior uh
that the more better thing though is
become one of my favorite runners of
your characters on the show
i did want to talk uh
about one thing you guys which is this
just the concept of three guys popping
their shirts off in a bank to try to
yeah uh
get a loan
yeah it's a really good idea the such a
funny build in the scene of you because
you set up the whole thing about the
wild card and now you're getting on each
other's case about like stepping on each
other's toes while you're at the bank
and then it culminating with which one
of us do you want
to take you in the back and bang you
with your shoes
out of the three of us out of the three
of us who's it going to be and then you
guys flexing for so i wanted to talk
about this
because this is how many years ago now
so this episode would have come out in
what 2008
yep yeah
how do you feel about this being out
there in the world would you take these
bodies back is this uh have you improved
upon since then
i would like to go ahead and point out
that if we were doing this to you it
would be wildly unacceptable
so let me just go ahead and point out
the hypocrisy that being said you did
this i didn't ask you to do this
no but i mean if we pulled up a picture
of you from 15 years ago and we said how
are you feeling about this yachty here
you know like you know this would be
frowned upon but um i'd love it i feel
great i would i would kill i would kill
for that fizzy
[Laughter]
actually i wouldn't kill for it i
wouldn't even i would barely even go to
the gym
[Laughter]
barely adjust your diet one bit yes
i'm gonna live my life man this i do
remember this being the the sort of year
that i started noticing myself you know
gaining a little weight around the
middle which is something that i just
genetically hadn't been able to do prior
to this season then all of a sudden i
was like oh no
my body's changing
you guys look great i think i look i
think
i think i am in better shape now than i
was then but it it differs from month to
month however i think i'm i'm healthier
than i was then because that was still
an era of coffee and cigarettes all day
long
uh however
the my skin
is what 12 years uh 13 years old
what is it christ 14 years older and
skin yeah there's just nothing you can
do about it the sun [ __ ] we've
established we glenn you hate the sun
right
the sun pisses yeah off it destroys your
skin
i'll say
your skin now
looks
it actually looks pretty good it's a
little it's a leave you've had enough
work done to wear
that rubbery glow yeah
lasers oh so one thing i'm doing at the
end of this scene is moving your pecs or
i'm trying i'm trying to move my which i
think i can still yeah i can still do
that yeah uh but i give her a look now
earlier in the in the episode there's a
really funny scene that was making me
laugh of that's so simple and stupid of
charlie
just giving looks just giving
expressions trying to find what the
world
the wild card faces
and it was just really funny and on the
day it was just charlie just making
faces
and so at the end of this scene i try to
make my sexiest face
to her
right
about
here
now that's good bud just trying to just
trying to also like doing this
charlie look if you pause it right at
this time code charlie is laughing am i
laughing yeah try this but look the body
looks great but you're laughing am i
loving him yeah
go to one frame right before and before
we cut out
i probably would be laughing
right there you see it you see the
transmission you see
for sure wow you guys are enjoying it's
funny it's funny the uh the i like the
uh that sort of in insecure slightly
insecure flexing yeah that we're all
doing is this cool
everyone's trying to do the posture that
they think makes their body look best
right right
right to get a loan to get gasoline wait
do you guys remember this conversation
there was
somebody put body makeup on i can't
remember who it was was it me or glenn
it was definitely gonna be one of you
guys who's tan yeah it was you it was
you rob i mean i always said i have my
always farmers dancers yeah glenn's got
his farmer's tail and so does charlie
dude i have like yeah
you put on
bodybuilding yeah i think i did and i
remember talking about it there and
saying wait i thought because it was one
of those situations where the makeup
department was like i think glenn wears
body makeup when he takes the shirt off
from time to time and which is not which
is not weird
you never had
not not up to that point uh i will i
will i do now uh but back then that's
actually a common practice and not that
weird and it's mostly to match your skin
tone of your face because when you wear
makeup you wear makeup and so when you
take your shirt off you put you so then
i remember going uh oh i guess we're
wearing body makeup okay so then they
paint you up with this like whatever
that makeup is and it's not that
dramatic
it's just a it's kind of like a spray
tan it just looks different than now
glenn looks very farmer tan and i
remember standing there
and i remember one of you guys being
like what the [ __ ] man i'm like well i
don't know i thought we were wearing
body makeup
i guess it doesn't look that it doesn't
look that good no no you can't tell no
thank you for letting me objectify you
guys
um it's a little leveling things out
yeah it's a little difficult um power
dynamics there i mean meg isn't meg is
empowering i think that that's what
you're suggesting i feel objectified yes
because meg is in a position of power
over us
she is the producer
okay now we have a suit yeah now we have
a suit
unfortunately she has no money so we
have to sell more ads no what we have is
that we can sell out so that we can sue
her and get the money back that's that's
good no it's not about that it's about
having that in your back pocket in case
something else goes down i mean it's
leverage
with a suit and we say actually we have
a counter suit exactly unless i cut that
out of this episode and then you guys
don't have any outsmarted again
speaking of
being the brains
and having good ideas like that
the brains the looks
the wild card
the muscle and the useless chick
such a great structure for this episode
and you switching roles and like trying
to how did you guys do you remember how
you came up with that
yeah that was just us being in the room
and talking about those i think it
started with the a team where we looked
at the a-team and that was like such a
perfect show where they decided right we
just need a a a
a stereotype not a stereotype what's the
word i'm looking for i said yes an
archetype for each individual character
so that everybody's distinct and
different but they all fulfill a role
and so when
it just laid itself out really
beautifully for us but then you you
realize it extends into so many
different stories
ghostbusters for example
speaking of which
this is the episode where we spent the
most amount of money ever that's right
to get the ghostbusters song
as i recall we spent so and we were we
were so blown away we were like oh let's
we'll put in the ghostbusters theme song
and they came back with a price and i
remember what it was
and we were like we've never even paid
anything close to this amount of money
to just put can i guess what it was
please was it two hundred thousand
dollars to play it no no no it wasn't
that much it wasn't that much
it was it was by far the most amount of
money we've ever been is it eighty i
think it was seventy seventy thousand it
was eighty okay it
and we would never we hadn't paid more
than twenty thousand dollars for a song
including like michael jackson songs and
app oh yeah and the da and the gang
dances their ass off i mean we have
doors yeah we got the doors the doors
didn't even cost and the reason was that
they were considering making another
ghostbusters at the time and they were
trying to protect for the possibility
which they didn't
and
glenn was vehemently opposed to paying
this and charlie and i were not yeah oh
yes oh yeah i think i was because i i
was like it doesn't i never i didn't
feel like it added that much like i i
like it i like it i like what it added
and um you know looking back now i'm
certainly glad we did it because like
you know what is it what does it make
amortized over 15 seasons but like at
the time yeah i think it was i just was
like yeah it's funny but it's not 80 000
funny yeah yeah yeah you're always
weighing it against some of the other
choices you made i will say
that i was watching this episode with
caitlin last night and the kids are in
other rooms because they could give two
flying [ __ ] about our television show
and then that song came up and i heard
leo from the other room go who are you
gonna call ghostbusters and then he
comes running into the room because he
wanted to hear the song and he wanted to
see what we were doing with the song so
it turns out it's transcended
generations because of that choice
it's a hell of a scenario
does he know it because of ghostbusters
afterlife no we watch the original
ghostbusters but i think it's also again
just one of those memeable
it's just it's all over the internet it
is
so it is worth it for the fact that you
start out the episode talking about
how to run the bar more efficiently and
you end up with an explosion in the
ghostbusters theme which just is such a
journey for the episode to take like
it's just really enjoyable remember we
took this episode and we screened it at
walter reed medical hospital in
washington dc yeah
yeah for our men and women
that's where danny played that great
prank on us
and yes
what would you have we talked about this
in the podcast no so we get to the hotel
i think fx you know pays for the flight
in the hotel yeah and uh
and uh we get to the hotel and they say
oh we're so sorry they said they said
can we bring you we're gonna bring you
guys up to your room and we were like
what do you mean room
yeah that's right yeah yeah that's right
that's right they're they're saying yeah
oh i'm so sorry
we were under the impression that you're
fx is only paying for one room
and it didn't surprise us right because
it was so early in the show and we're
such a low budget thing and we're like
oh man they're sticking us all in one
room together
well not only that but that the guy
actually said that there weren't we were
like we were like well that's just not
gonna happen um and he was like ah we
don't have any like this is the only
room we have left and he was like let's
go can i just give you guys a tour of it
yeah he's like let me just show it to
you and maybe you'll find it acceptable
and uh
i remember
you
you you were very unhappy i did not
handle those situations yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh i said we just got off a flight yeah
we were grumpy um disrespected
yeah being told no this is what you're
going to do you're all going to sleep in
this room and i remember we were
thinking like oh screw we'll go find
some other hotel or something so we go
up to the room
and it's you know a single room and then
out of the closet comes danny
well first first of all he shows us the
he shows us the suite and it is pretty
nice for one person
uh or two people you know a couple or
something but and and but he's like but
you know of course this this
we have a cot set up in the corner they
had a cot there so one of us was meant
to sleep in a cot
so he basically was trying to sell us on
this this whole thing
and then uh yeah and then out of the
closet danny pops out
with uh i think he had a bottle of booze
or something i don't know yeah yeah now
this poor hotel staff is like we don't
want to be a part of this we don't know
but they nailed it this guy i know i
know he's yeah he did i think for me
it was it was at that time because now
we're four
seasons in
and it still felt that everywhere we
went
nobody knew the show nobody gave a [ __ ]
about the show and we were just kind of
i don't know we would go on these
promotional tours and we were just
treated as like danny's like staff and
bodyguard or whatever it would be and
the suggestion that all four of us would
stay in the same room was not that crazy
if if we were to go to a hotel now you
would know it was a goof in the very
beginning
but at this time it was not that
unfounded we were still sharing a
trailer in season two we had a we shared
a honey wagon so the thought that fx
would put us up or the hotel staff would
just say yeah sure these
these animals will just sleep in one bed
was not that crazy so i don't i don't
think i handled it well it was a level
of disrespect that we had become
accustomed to yes
yeah so if anybody's doing the uh
re-watch with us and they watch the
waterboarding scene with caitlyn just
know
that she was being waterboarded
yeah i was looking at that i'm like
she's being wonderful and she she's
watching it and saying no no that was
actually hell i was being tortured and
you see when when he when he's flushes
the urinal it's just hitting the top of
her head but when he's pouring it on her
that's what the
fabric with the fabric over it now why
not
just say get a fabric
that isn't porous yeah that has maybe a
towel look on one side spend all the
money on the gussets we spent all the
money on the ghostbusters because when
the wet towel is over your mouth that is
waterboarding it's like suffocating that
is how they're waterboarding water going
up her nose and in her mouth while she's
trying to breathe yes it gives you the
sensation of drowning basically uh but
you actually you aren't actually
drowning because there's enough air
getting in yes but you're but you know
you're you're breathing in
the water
yes you're breathing
and the water as it comes in but the
towel is the towel is is creating enough
it's true truly torture you're not
drowning somebody you're torturing them
well and the wet towel suctions to your
suctions to your face right so you so
there's you're not getting any air
that's not coming through that sopping
wet towel yes
and she reminded me that her hands are
behind her back which was part of being
bound but also supporting her back which
at this point was broken oh my god oh
jesus at this point in shooting
her back was broken and she was healing
but she healed very quickly because it
was broken over the fourth of july
weekend
um and um and we shut down production
for i don't know a few weeks and then
came right back and there she was
getting waterboarded it's um it's
torture but it's not torture on the
level of say being asked i'll sleep in
the same hotel room which is just
insufferable and yeah i don't know which
is worse um
i think this is one of the first
episodes tim roach got because um
he's doing the voice of the of the golf
uh oh right commentator yeah yeah that
was roche unless
josh cut it and uh
and tim just no roach got that i i i do
remember that yeah roach cut that
episode for sure and it was it was it
may have actually been the first episode
that he that he um edited for us but uh
that was definitely him yeah that was
his first episode yep the gang solves
the gas crisis off the good stuff yeah
but i was watching that scene rob and i
was looking at and i'm like
i don't i mean this is indistinguishable
from actual waterboarding she's being
waterboarded right now but i don't
remember
i remember her being upset about it
being like this is
yeah this is not funny beyond
we also created apparently a a a uh a
tremendous amount of controversy a few
years later but it never got to us and
then um i heard a few years after that
that it was a fire that was put out at
the highest of levels at the news corp
organization
what is that apparently
when we use that photograph of bruce
mathis accepting an award
in in the newspaper he's accepting some
humanitarian award and then frank says
he's get he's he's in cahoots with
terrorists
yes apparently the man that is in that
newspaper is a revered
public figure in the middle east and i
think we should look up who he is he is
not a terrorist
and i think there was what does that
have to do with any possible frank
stereotyping i mean no but it's like
literally yeah
that's literally the joke
of course but i don't know that the
people of saudi arabia the police are
necessarily
are in on the joke and it didn't it
didn't happen in real time it wasn't
known for
i mean they're pretty well known for uh
having good sense of humor over there
they love
hello listeners
and creeps this is mag jumping in with a
little follow-up so i did a little
digging and found out that the newspaper
photo used in this scene was digitally
altered after the episode aired
apparently the man in the original photo
was a friend of rupert murdoch's so word
came down from the top that it had to be
scrubbed from the episode
that is what happened now back to the
show
i want to talk about another thing that
came out of this episode that i hear
repeated a lot which is uh i know how to
count dude that line are you talking
about
the gasoline yeah counting the liquid
how are you going to count a liquid uh i
know how to count dude
you do it you do it you do it you do it
you do it because i can't you do it
because i can't oh right because i can't
i guess i can't
right
i love the scenes that with the gas
station guy oh yeah
we're gonna tell you where it hurts your
dick
your dick no not his dick man
why aren't you getting this
and then you flipping over that lighter
like at a moment's notice like that's
always the way the wild card goes that's
kind of a dynamic we haven't done and it
could have been really funny like the
three of us trying to
poorly threaten someone i feel like we
haven't done a lot of threatening mm-hmm
but threatening could be very funny
but do you remember do you guys remember
uh we i can't remember why or maybe it
was i think it was maybe because we were
at an actual gas station we could not
actually light that zippo lighter
so we had to do uh what was at the time
for us a very intensive special effect
which was just to put a flame coming out
of that zippo now rob i'm sure you
remember this because i remember you and
i just absolutely
losing our minds
at how inept it seemed that they were we
would come in there and look at what
they comped in and there'd be like this
giant flame coming out of it and we're
like well no we're like can you make it
look like a uh oh i don't know a zippo
lighter because that's what it is can we
you know you don't want to be a dick but
you're i just remember thinking like
yeah that's cool now uh can we do one
where it looks like the actual thing
that we're holding
you [ __ ] idiot like why do you not
know what that looks like you're this is
what you do it was the flame guy that
worked at the special effects place like
his whole specialty was fire
fire stuff and he doesn't know what his
job is called flame he was he was the
flames guy yeah right well they did a
great job on the fireball that's for
[ __ ] they did
that was fascinating to do such a great
job on the fireball but then we could
just couldn't get them to do the like
that was that was an actual fireball
dude that was an actual
that was an actual one that was an
actual fireball yeah so we had a guy
yeah we had a guy standing in front of a
green screen yeah blew an actual fire so
we had the element
that's right we had the element so why
didn't we do that with a lighter why
didn't we shoot a little flame coming
off a lighter and then i i think we did
um
glenn laid into this guy like he was the
hotel manager wasn't no i did not i did
not i did not i was i was uh but i
wanted to i wanted to
yeah you call yourself a flame guy
you're no flame guy
that's not what a lighter does
what was that in the barrels you guys
remember what you were drinking because
you slurp it up but then it's just the
more memorable one is charlie siphoning
it out of his well let me tell you
something when you siphon out of a car
whether you've put something in there or
not there's been gas in that car so you
do get i remember getting like a
mouthful of fumey whatever
we put it there i can't remember what we
put in there but what did it taste like
i mean i i don't know i've never
remembered probably because i drank
gasoline you know what i mean like this
is
i like that you point out that it's such
a waste of time because we're we're
we're we're burning up the gas and
uh gang we want you to know that this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
if you're not familiar with better help
it's an online therapy service that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with licensed therapists all
around the world
how it works is you answer questions and
better help assesses your needs and
matches you with the right person to
talk to in less than two days it's not
just about who's around you or who's
available it's about who's best for you
yeah i've actually used better help
before because i had a sort of temporary
problem that i wanted to see a therapist
quickly about and it was really really
easy to use i signed up and they matched
me with someone really quickly well
that's about yeah i mean that's the best
part of it right you get matched to the
the person that's the most right for you
you're not like
tethered to you know whoever's in your
area whoever's available whoever you can
get an appointment with you can get uh
matched with the right person from all
over the world and you don't have to sit
in traffic and go to the person's office
you get to just do it right from your
laptop computer that's right always
sunny podcast listeners get 10 off their
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
sunny creeps you are already reading
this with your eyeballs but listeners
that's h-e-l-p
not better health go to betterhelp.com
sunny for 10 off your first month of
therapy
[Music]
[Applause]
i do feel like this
episode and this season is where we
really found the show you know where
the first season we're discovering what
it is in the second
we're refining it and danny's coming in
so that's a new element and the third
we're trying some big swings and maybe
some things are a little more cartoony
than where we want to go and this season
we're really kind of settling into it
and the character dynamics and how we
relate to each other are really tight in
this episode so i think this is where it
really works you can feel it in that
scene after the bank
i love that you guys are trying to move
on to the next step in the plan and then
dennis is just hung up on i can't
believe you guys we very rarely
very rarely do that and it stood out to
me and i really liked it
that dennis wants to can we just have a
heart to heart for a second
yeah he's uncomfortable
i don't want to carry this around that
that that didn't sound that was my thing
and you guys took it yeah it hurt and it
hurt yeah it's that's actually very very
kind of mature way of approaching the
situation you know what i mean like far
more mature than than how these
characters normally act to come to your
friends and say
hey listen i got to bring something up
because this really this really bothered
me when you guys did this like that
that's actually a healthy
way to confront somebody about how their
behavior affected your affected you yeah
i remember feeling that too that it's
like oh this is interestingly out of
character right to see him like a little
broken about something
but also but also to be broken about
that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the vanity and the ridiculousness
is still there because what i'm hurt
about is just
so ridiculous but that's your thing
we've established that that's your thing
and if you take my thing away from me
then what role do i have
then you very quickly realize that
you're
not only not only did you get that back
but then you also added a thing so you
took one away from from me
wasn't that the same scene
and the looks and you're the muscle yeah
but you could yeah because you confused
my bossiness for bradiness which is
definitely a real conversation at some
point
that is what is his personality
that is who he
is um
i have a question for you guys have you
ever sold anything door-to-door
i have
did you did you sell meat or knives you
sold meat or knives right
buddy i
i sold
i sold meat yeah it was a uh
not a job that i had for a long time it
was it was a crazy crazy job driving
around in a refrigerated truck and
trying to sell people
like large quantities of meat you know
like meat in bulk like somebody knocks
on your door and is like
i got a truck full of meat uh you you
you interested in that you know like did
you ever get any sales
yeah i made a few i made a few but i
wasn't good at it because i was never
good at it at uh i was never good at
just i don't know sales mini stuff like
bullshitting it felt like [ __ ]
because it was well have we solved the
podcast crisis today
yeah maybe i was going to ask
if you guys wanted to give us your best
wild card face
because uh
i know that glenn's ready to give his
wild card face right now let's do it
yeah let's do it i'll do it go ahead and
go oh you want me to start yeah why did
you start i feel like maybe i should go
last you know what do you want do you
mind taking off the sunglasses because i
feel like so much is in the eyes yeah
yeah actually charlie could you because
my arm yeah thank you i appreciate that
yeah
uh okay all right ready yep
oh that's great do another one yeah
oh
that's the one
that's the one
yeah you can't do it yeah
i'd also talk about the looks of things
i'd also like to talk about um the sexy
drawings that dennis this is the first
episode i think where he makes no
no
[Laughter]
um
version of an ideal woman who's like
completely uh disproportionate
yeah yeah giant breasts and a tiny waist
does casey draw casey is a great artist
no that was actually i think that was
actually um
it was a female props master that we had
uh that that drew all those photos oh
great
we don't make women do anything it says
in the script and we said just draw an
attractive woman like this this is what
you came up with this is what you're
doing hey let's go with it you know
that's funny for us
what do you want do you want women to
have more jobs in hollywood or do you
want to come on what are we supposed to
do better for them it's more better for
you to take a job and do what we say you
know we've established this we've
established
it makes more sense to give a woman the
opportunity to draw a one yeah yes um
yeah in the way that a man
explains it yeah
you've explained to it we told her how
to do it he allowed her to do the work
and if you push back we'll take this
[ __ ] to the supreme court and we will
win we'll of course we'll win this is a
great time to be a man we will get our
man's way
we had a rough run we had a rough run
for like three four years but i think
we're back right oh yeah
what
we
[Music]
you